just a few hours after the New Yorker
broke its story charging New York
Democratic Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman with abusing four women he
resigned his office now isn't it rich
that he set himself up as the hero of
the me2 movement by using his office to
sue Harvey Weinstein women were coerced
into facilitating Harvey Weinstein's
misconduct sometimes they were targets
themselves if they refused they were
threatened they knew how pervasive it
was and not only did they fail to stop
it they enabled it and covered it up we
have never seen anything as despicable
as what we seen here well guess it takes
one to know one
well Schneiderman was also the darling
of the anti-trump media and fellow Dems
for challenging donald trump's nearly
every move he's filed over 100 lawsuits
or administrative actions against the
president trying to stop his daca plan
the travel ban health care deregulation
it went on and on
Sneiderman quickly became a champion of
the left resistance a kind of super hero
which was how comedian and fan girl
Samantha bee attempted to frame him on
this now scrubbed episode of her show oh
my god
[Music]
you're gonna save us we're gonna do it
but that requires a lot of people other
than state attorneys general getting
engaged
depends on what getting engaged means
well next time
Samantha be careful oh that's so bad
really write bad next time do a better
job choosing your superheroes now
although I gotta say he did like to
dress up apparently so maybe the
superhero thing does work well
Schneiderman tried to explain away the
charges against him this way he said in
the privacy of intimate relationships
I've engaged in role-playing in other
consensual sexual activity I have not
assaulted anyone Superman didn't beat
the hell out of Lois Lane Erik for women
romantically involved with New York's
top cop alleged that Schneiderman abused
them including claims that he smacked
spit on choked and sexually and racially
demeaned his victims what a guy he
threatened to tap their phones or have
someone follow or even kill them if they
attempted to leave the relationship as
New York's highest ranking law
enforcement official this is the guy who
attended the women's march along by the
way with Harvey Weinstein and he would
later use his prosecutorial authority
against Weinstein and fought to get his
victims greater compensation so it was
yay Erik thank you thank you thank you
well as his profile rose as a leading
defender of women in the wake of the me2
movement his victims were persuaded
somehow to come forward but they met
their own resistance from the left in
those conversations after the fact a lot
of their friends and loved ones said
don't do it don't speak out against him
and in some cases that was because they
feared the risk of reprisals but also in
some cases Alison those friends warned
them off of talking because they thought
that he had the power to do too much
good for the Democratic Party Wow in
other words so long as Schneiderman was
willing to use his
office to block the Trump agenda and was
working to tear down Trump keep your
tales of abuse quiet ladies take one for
the team what's a little collateral
damage right you know it reminds me of
how Harvey skated for so many years sure
he had money and he had power to make or
break a career but he also had the right
political views he had the coolest
friends and all those politicians he
raised millions for valuable commodity
but back to Schneiderman most of them
knew or should have known about its
history a lot of the Democrats people
who are championing him and a lot of the
allegation against him but they kept on
their blinders again how convenient if
this were a Republican he would be
decried on every cable show with barely
a break for breaking news on the Iran
deal but instead of going after
Schneiderman for his misdeeds in his
abuse of office today's never Trump
media merely use the scandal it's just
another vehicle for trashing
conservatives Democrats are have been
trying to be very consistent when
members of their own have been called
out to draw a contrast but there is not
a lot of indication that this
administration unfortunately likes to
take the high road particularly when it
comes to political office all I'm saying
this was area take him down by lifting
women up in the defense of their right
thank and yet I don't think the lift up
is a move they've got a lot of muscle
memory on right now what is our world we
live in that Donald Trump is accused of
sexually harassing dozens of women and
admits that he sexually assaults women
on tape and yet people like Mike Pence
talk about what a great Christian he is
one of the presidents
Bo's New York Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman resigns over sexual abuse
allegations is this a tipping point for
Trump what is this a tipping point for
Trump
how about is this a tipping point for
the left and the people who claim to be
protecting America's women or is
slapping choking spitting in making
women of color call a man master now
acceptable behavior well until it's
discovered White House counselor Kelly
and Conway certainly reached her tipping
point yesterday she nailed
Schneiderman's hypocrisy when she
tweeted out gotcha
above a snide ermine tweet where he
wrote no one is above the law and I'll
continue to remind President Trump and
his administration of that every day
well instead of acknowledging
Schneiderman's loathesome and perhaps
even criminal behavior planned
parenthood action that's the political
arm of the abortion giant decided to go
after wait for it
Kellyanne made tweeted out Kellyanne
polls delete your account okay now what
all this tells us is what so many of us
have thought really for a long time the
left while claiming to be the true
honest champions of women at many times
that many points consider them to be
disposable especially when they become
politically inconvenient Eric
Schneiderman was a stalwart political
ally of the left but he's out of the
picture now so move on quickly move on
and it's back to vilifying Trump and any
woman who supports his agenda are any of
you fed up with this rank hypocrisy me
too and that's the angle